[Musik]
in deutschland ist er mit einer million
euro verschuldet doch in florida führt
michael wendler ein leben in luxus im
internet sind private us kreditkarten
abrechnungen des sängers aufgetaucht sie
zeigen deutlich dass wendler dieses jahr
immer wieder üppige einkäufe weil luxus
händlern gemacht hat bei louis vuitton
blätterte wendler im juli
4761 dollar hin dafür gibt es zum
beispiel eine pigmentierte glattleder
handtasche und eine jogginghose
kleinkram im vergleich zu wendlers
ausgaben beim edel-juwelier tiffany in
q3 10 einkäufe seit anfang des jahres
für insgesamt 35
1988 dollar bei hermès gab ist immerhin
noch schmuck für 708 dollar doch damit
war noch lange nicht schluss luxus
treter bei jutta für 2129 dollar und
knapp 5000 dollar ließ er in der
zahnklinik waterside ästhetik dentistry
vermutlich für das strahlend weiße wände
lächeln
und bei uns im studio service live show
chefin giannina kirsch so dreist muss
man erst mal sein steht da unten drunter
bei uns frech oder ich warte ja ich
arbeite ja auch immer noch an dem
strahlenden lächeln wieder wenzler es
noch 5000 euro genau also nein 13 mal
innerhalb von neun monaten zu tiffany's
zu gehen insgesamt über 87.000 euro
auszugeben für luxus shopping wenn man
doch eine million euro schulden beim
finanzamt hat in deutschland das ist in
meinen augen ehrlicherweise einfach nur
noch dreist aber wir wissen er shop ja
nicht nur bei hermès oder bei tiffany's
vermutlich für seine laura sondern auch
immobilien offensichtlich ja der wendler
hat ja bis vor kurzem in cape coral
gelebt in einem sehr schönen haus dieses
haus hat er verkauft und hat mega gewinn
gemacht über 400.000 dollar gewinnen da
die immobilienpreise einfach so
gestiegen sind in amerika in den letzten
jahren und man würde dann ja mein hat
der rentner da könnte doch jetzt mal
diese 400.000 euro dollar nutzen um
seine gläubiger zu zahlen nein das tut
er nicht er lebt jetzt in einem
mietshaus von diesem mietshaus haben wir
auch schöne aufnahmen vielleicht können
wir die mal sehen da sieht man nämlich
schon so ganz schön die halloween deko
garten dafür bezahlt da
6300 dollar miete des müssen muss man
erstmal schaffen also ein stell ich weiß
nicht was ihr seid ja also ich könnte
mir 6300 dollar miete im monat nicht
leisten ich könnte mir ist aber auch
nicht erlauben für 87.000 dollar shoppen
zu gehen wir haben wie gesagt dass den
gewinn den er gemacht hat hat er halt
nicht benutzt um das damit irgendwie das
geld die schulden abzubezahlen nein er
hat sich neue grundstücke gekauft und
zwar zwei grundstücke in punta gorda das
liegt im südwesten floridas
auch an einem an einem jahr an einem
kanal am pace river eine sehr schöne
kleine stadt hat glaube ich noch nicht
mal 20.000 einwohner und hat zwei
grundstücke gekauft direkt nebeneinander
die schön am wasser werden genau direkt
am wasser am peace river
wahnsinnig schönes mildes klima im
südwesten von florida diese beiden
grundstücke gekauft für
275.000 dollar laut unseren
informationen und da möchte er jetzt
bauen interessant ist ja aber auch
dass er dieses grundstück nicht als
privatmann gekauft hat er hat dieses
grundstück er hat eine firma gegründet
laut unseren informationen mit einem
partner zusammen er ist der kopf dieser
firma und
über diese firma hat er diese
grundstücke gekauft
darf er das denn oder ist das irgendwie
so grauzonen naja legalität ist schon
die frage ist warum tut er das warum
kauft dass ich das nicht als privatmann
und das deutet natürlich darauf hin dass
das wieder ein trick ist um
nicht als privatmann besitz zu haben
damit ihnen das am ende des tages nicht
gesendet werden kann also das deutet
natürlich sehr sehr darauf hin er hat
uns auch exklusiv seine strategie
verraten wie er seine schulden loswerden
ja das ist eine sehr ihre strategie das
kann nicht gleich vorweg sagen wir haben
natürlich auf die schulden angesprochen
und wir können das zitat ja gerne mal
gucken oder wasser zu uns gesagt hat
jana
hornig bleiben für immer zusammen und
den vier jahren verlange ich von oliver
pocher die eine million euro die er
öffentlich darauf setzte dass ich meine
frau laura von mir trend und damit
bezahle ich dann spätestens das
finanzamt des einer klaren strategie das
ist für mich eine absolute verhöhnung
der gläubiger also wenn man wirklich
noch sitze darüber macht dass man
schulden hat dann hat man den ernst der
lage nicht verstanden also dass das
grenzt für mich tatsächlich auch ein
bisschen an realitätsverlust zu sagen ja
ich habe mir mit dem pocher eine wette
laufen dass meine frau mich verlässt und
da hat er gesagt er gibt damit 1
millionen euro wenn er die wenn er die
verliert warte ich doch mal darauf
bleibe ich doch mal mit der l'or
zusammen das wird nämlich nicht
passieren und dann habe ich ja auch geld
die wendler wie wäre es einfach mal mit
weniger luxus shopping dann könnten sie
vielleicht auch eher rückläufig sein und
auch mit weniger immobilien shopping und
ähnliches aber er hat uns ja noch was
verraten und zwar hat er ein comeback
angedroht er hatte ein comeback und eine
rückkehr nach deutschland angedroht im
online-shop oder
ja ich komme zurück nach deutschland
heißt es nicht mit wohnort der bleibt
die usa und nein ich hatte niemals
vorher meine karriere zu beenden das
haben immer nur andere behauptet
vielleicht wird es 2022 wieder konzerte
geben und höchstwahrscheinlich kommt
mein neues album zeitgleich meine
karriere fängt erst so richtig an wow
wow
wow ich wusste nicht so richtig ob ich
lachen oder weinen soll als ich das
gehört habe denn natürlich hat er seine
karriere selbst zerstört und zwar in dem
moment in dem er angefangen hat im
internet corona verschwörungstheorien zu
verbreiten das war einfach das ende
seiner karriere in dem moment haben
partner wie rtl oder auch andere
werbekunden gesagt es tut mir leid aber
mit ihnen können und wollen wir in der
zukunft nicht mehr zusammenarbeiten
dass er jetzt tatsächlich denkt dass er
es schafft eine karriere wieder zu
starten die auch noch größer wird als
vorher dass er wirklich noch denkt er
findet neue werbepartner
konzertveranstalter et cetera das finde
ich schon krass weil das stelle ich mir
nicht so einfach und ich glaube auch
nicht dass das so einfach sein wird
dafür müsste er eigentlich eine rolle
rückwärts machen sich für all das was er
im letzten den letzten jahren gemacht
hat was krone angeht was diese krassen
verschwörungstheorien angeht ich meine
hat die bundesregierung kritisiert er
hat uns medien kritisiert gesagt wir
werden die geschnappt werden werden
sterben gesehen werden wir haben
irgendwie in sowas in der richtung also
wenn er da sich nicht wirklich richtig
krass distanziert dann glaube ich nicht
dass es ihm so leicht fällt neue
kooperationspartner zu finden das andere
sind natürlich die fans
dass er immer noch fans hat das ist so
dass wahrscheinlich auch menschen auf
sein konzert gehen würden weil sie seine
musik lieben auch das fair enough kann
ich mir durchaus vorstellen aber finde
dann erstmal den konzertveranstalter und
findet erst mal den der das alles für
dich organisiert das bezweifle ich so
ein bisschen und freunde jahr soll er
gerne mal zurück nach deutschland kommen
dann möchte ich mal sehen was passiert
denn hier gibt es ja auch noch ein paar
fahren verfahren gegen ihn sollte er
sich dennoch vielleicht mal stellen die
gläubiger würden sich wahrscheinlich
freuen wenn er ein bisschen mehr in die
nähe kommen ist die gläubiger würden
sich in der tat freuen ja vielleicht
laden wir ihnen dann ja hier mal ein
dann kann er sich unseren fragen auch
mal stellen
[Musik]